a new report is renewing questions about
the origins of covet 19.
according to the wall street journal u.s
intelligence believes
three researchers in wuhan got so sick
in november 2019
that they had to be hospitalized now
that's before the first cases of the
virus were disclosed
nancy cordes is at the white house with
more on this story
now nancy china maintains that the
coronavirus did not come from a lab
what are u.s officials saying now
especially since china's not exactly
been so forthcoming
good morning gail well on one hand white
house officials are neither confirming
nor
denying the validity of this
intelligence but
on the other hand cbs news has learned
that some u.s government officials who
have been given
additional classified briefings on this
matter have now become
more open to the theory that coronavirus
originated
in a lab we need that data
we need that information from the
chinese government white house officials
say the ongoing mystery about kovid's
origins
demonstrates why china needs to share
everything it knows
according to the wall street journal an
intelligence report said that
three employees at this wuhan lab for
studying viruses
were hospitalized in november 2019
a month earlier than the first reported
cases of kovid 19.
on monday the chinese foreign ministry
pushed back
calling the reports totally untrue and
the director of the wuhan institute of
virology insisted
the lab has not been aware of sick
researchers in autumn 2019
and i don't even know where such
information came from
the most likely etiology of
this pathogen and wuhan was a from a
laboratory
you know escaped trump officials have
long suggested
covid19 was created in the lab either
intentionally or unintentionally but dr
anthony fauci told cbs yesterday
he still believes it is highly likely
that the virus first occurred
naturally in the environment spreading
from animals to humans
though he hasn't ruled out the lab
theory i think that we should continue
to investigate
what went on in china jamie metzel a
geopolitics expert says it's crucial to
learn
about the viruses origins the very
strong circumstantial evidence
for a lab incident origin is growing if
we don't
understand the origins of this pandemic
we will be
at unnecessary risk for the next one
an investigation by the world health
organization earlier this year
determined that the risk of a lab
accident in china was
extremely low but the who did not have
access to crucial chinese data and
samples and so enrique they are now
considering
a second probe nancy thank you